Welcome to statistics,
the science of decisions.
But before we get started with
the class Sean, Katie, and
I want to talk to you a little bit about
what our expectations are for you and
what you should expect
to learn in the class.
>> As you know,
this is an online course and
online courses differ greatly
from in-class courses.
First, you will not be coming to
a classroom two to three times a week.
Instead, you'll be working from home or
wherever.
Whether it's on a mobile device,
a tablet or a PC.
One thing that you should notice is
that this is a self-paced course.
That means, you are responsible for
deciding when and
where you complete the material.
>> Because this is online and
this is self-paced,
a lot of the responsibility
falls on you.
You need to find the motivation
to come to class,
and, by class, I mean going to
the online course every day.
It's important that you distribute
your learning over time.
Online courses,
it's easy to fall away and
forget about them because you're
not driving to a campus every day.
So you have to remember to check in and
time manage, in a way, so
that you are learning a little
bit about statistics every day.
That will make the learning better and
that will make the course
a lot more enjoyable.
>> Yes, it is important for
you guys to take responsibility, but the
main objective is for you guys to learn.
And, yes, you're going to struggle
sometimes, but that's the whole point.
At Udacity, we want to give you
a quiz to make you struggle first, so
that you form your own ideas about this
concept before we start teaching you
the formalized statistical
way of learning it.
>> I would also encourage you to
take advantage of your classmates.
There's a lot of knowledge out there and
there's a lot of knowledge about
statistics already, so use each other.